20 years ago the world fell to [__]
cities put up walls to protect
themselves and threw the criminals out
so they could fight over what was left
but there are humble [__] like
me delivering cargo from one walled City
to another that's where the cars and
guns come in
[Music]
so if I'm here then the exit is oh they
have a Foot Locker
welcome to New San Francisco I want to
hire you pick up a package bring it back
I can make your every wish come true so
John what do you wish for toilet paper
to apply I think I can do better
it's rude not to introduce yourself
before pulling a gun on someone
if you put the gun down I'll drop you
off as close as I can to where you're
going it's just quiet she don't talk
[__] eat [__] much you have no
idea what sound is even the people
trying to bring the law back are
dangerous This Is Our Land these are all
roads and they're gonna have to go
through Vegas
above Noah rules Vegas John hi everybody
I've never seen anyone cut off a human
head and catch it as good as that
oh my God
this never happened to me before really
oh man
[Music]
what's down the red line
cool screams